Serial killers, gorgon anatomy, and one very
animated disembodied hand. Tim Burton's
"Wednesday" is the perfect family show!
"Attempted murder. How would
that have looked on your record?"
"Terrible. Everyone would know
I failed to get the job done."
Netflix gave "Wednesday" an eight-episode
season order back in February of 2021,
officially getting the ball rolling on the
project. Tim Burton signed on to direct
and executive produce while Al Gough and
Miles Millar also serve as co-showrunners.
Production ran from September 2021 to March
2022, so when can we expect to see it?
On September 23, Netflix announced
the series would drop November 23rd
and revealed a brand-new poster. Wednesday
stands poised, twirling an umbrella, outside
what is likely Nevermore Academy towering in the
background. As show star Jenna Ortega has stated,
her version of Wednesday Addams has something
hidden away just below the surface. While the
series will miss the Halloween season, "Wednesday"
does arrive just in time for Thanksgiving and
quality time with the family. Nothing like good
ole fashioned murder to bring folks together.
Netflix's "Wednesday" boasts quite the stacked
cast from top to bottom. As far as the Addams
themselves go, Jenna Ortega plays Wednesday,
Catherine Zeta-Jones portrays her mother,
Morticia, and Luis Guzmán joins them as
family patriarch Gomez. Isaac Ordonez
takes on Wednesday's brother, Pugsley,
George Burcea plays Lurch the butler,
and Victor Dorobantu — or his hand, at
least — will appear as Thing. Outside
of the Addams family unit, viewers will
get to see a host of incredible actors.
The extended cast of "Wednesday" includes
Gwendoline Christie as Larissa Weems,
Jamie McShane as Sheriff Donovan Galpin, Joy
Sunday as Bianca Barclay, Emma Myers as Enid
Sinclair, Naomi J. Ogawa as Yoko Tanaka,
and a laundry list of other strong names.
Additionally, the actress behind the 1990s version
of Wednesday Addams, Christina Ricci, will appear
on the Netflix series, though it's unknown who
she'll play. When it comes to Uncle Fester, he is
a part of the series, but the character's casting
was at least initially being kept under wraps.
The series is meant to be an offshoot of "The
Addams Family." Netflix describes it as a:
"Sleuthing, supernaturally
infused mystery that follows
Wednesday as a student at Nevermore Academy."
"Variety" says that the story will involve
Wednesday developing psychic powers and
attempting to control them. In the meantime,
the town surrounding the school is terrorized
by an ongoing killing spree. This mystery
appears to involve events from the past,
and apparently has a connection to her parents.
Wednesday has to navigate all this while
navigating student life, complete with new
relationships and the idiosyncrasies of her fellow
students. We have a feeling she's going to have a
harder time whipping her new classmates into shape
than those campers at Camp Chippewa in "Addams
Family Values," when she staged a revolt that
eventually led to the destruction of the camp.
On August 17, 2022, Netflix gave "Addams
Family" fans what they've been waiting for:
the "Wednesday" trailer. Despite clocking in
at just over two minutes long, the teaser did
an excellent job of explaining what the series
is all about. We see Wednesday get in trouble
at a school by letting piranhas loose in a
student-occupied pool before we jump to her
parents shipping her off to Nevermore Academy.
We get a look at some of the school's personnel,
students, and the academy itself
as things really go off the rails.
Upon her arrival, we find that Wednesday's new
school isn't all that it's cracked up to
be. Wednesday narrates in the trailer:
"Little did I know that I'd be stepping into a
nightmare, full of mystery, mayhem, and murder."
While that might sound horrifying to the average
person, Wednesday has a different feeling.
"I think I'm going to love it here."
After a quick and appropriately chaotic montage,
the trailer ends with Wednesday snapping her
fingers twice, an incredibly appropriate homage
to the famous "Addams Family" theme song.
Nevermore Academy was founded in 1791. Its sole
mission has been to celebrate and nurture those
who lie on the fringes of society. Principal Weems
ponders an interesting question in the trailer.
"In a world full of normies,
do you feel like an outcast?"
She adds that she too has felt like an
oddity and invites the audience to learn
more about the academy and all that is in
store through a special video presentation.
The Academy offers a wide range of studies,
including Werewolf Reproduction and Gorgon
Anatomy. That's only the beginning of the
experience for the students that pass the
application process. Extracurricular activities
run the gamut, from painting to archery. The
academy also boasts such notable alumni as
gothic novelist Edgar Allan Poe and Ignatius It,
as well as Morticia and Gomez Addams.
In the words of two of the students,
the well-respected institute is open to
"students from all walks of life... and death."
In a featurette released on August 24,
Ortega opens up about her strenuous schedule
preparing to play the show's titular character.
Worried about stepping into the role's legacy,
she took fencing and cello lessons
twice a week. Her commitment extended
into every facet of the work, including
nailing down Wednesday's physicality.
"I would walk like Wednesday, and
I think that people thought I might
be kinda crazy because I wanted her to
be specific and certain and assertive."
Director Tim Burton even compared Ortega's
approach to that of a silent movie actress
because of her ability to convey her thoughts
without words. He praised her performance
saying that he couldn't imagine anyone else
in the role. While previous iterations of
the character were "cartoony" in Burton's
estimation, a sense of reality was brought
to the story to give Wednesday even
more grounded character elements.
Ortega also notes that this Wednesday is much
more socially awkward than previous iterations,
and her confidence is "more concealed" compared
to what fans may have seen in the past.
Christina Ricci forever immortalized Wednesday
in '90s films "The Addams Family" and "Addams
Family Values." While her role in the
forthcoming series remains top secret,
she told Collider that the role
is outrageous and different than
anything she'd ever done. She also shared
that she especially enjoyed spending time
in a world where everybody seems so
thrilled to be doing the wrong thing.
For Ricci, what makes "Wednesday" even
more special is the fact that Tim Burton
asked her directly to be involved. She said,
"To be asked to be part of a new
version of this thing that is a
huge part of my identity and my history
and my life, I was really touched by it."
While Ricci's Wednesday has a sharp intensity
to it, Ortega's turn brings a different energy,
one that Ricci thinks is smart, timely and
appropriate. She also observes that the breakout
star possesses the, quote, "spirit of dignity
and self-respect that Wednesday's so loved for."
For her part, Ortega commented how "terrified"
she was to be filming with Ricci, especially
when getting into the exact same costume Ricci
wore 30 years ago. She then swapped compliments,
noting how Ricci's performance in the '90s films
was "flawlessly done" and "pitch-perfect," adding,
"I wouldn't change anything about it, which is
another reason it was hard for me to do this job."